[Música]
saludo en directo América con más Romero
y el día de hoy el tema va por el
envejecimiento del cerebro y Qué podemos
hacer para retrasarlo Buen día para
ustedmar Buenos días Ángel así es Es un
estudio del instituto de investigaciones
del hospital del mar de Barcelona que
traigo de allí directamente publicado en
la revista biology y demuestra que el
envejecimiento de nuestro cerebro por
primera vez no solo se debe a nuestra
edad sino que también depende de lo que
le llaman la edad biológica que tiene
mucho más que ver con nuestras
condiciones ambientales de vida y
también con los hábitos saludables
comentamos este hallazgo con el Doctor
Carlos Pérez médico infectólogo de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia es un
gusto poder volver a saludarle en este
año 2023 doctor cuéntenos el estudio
compara la edad biológica con la edad
cronológica cuál es esa primera
diferencia
Hola buenos días para todos acá lo
importante es diferenciar que la edad
cronológica pues son los años que pasan
en nuestra vida y la edad biológica está
relacionado con lo que estos
investigadores ven en el ácido nucleico
en el dna que hace parte de nuestras
células que muestra una aceleración en
algunos pacientes decir que se metila
que se altera Y eso es lo que llaman
edad biológica una edad digamos celular
y otra sería la edad que son los años
que pasan esa correlación entre esas dos
edades plantean algunas diferencias en
el área cerebral Y eso es lo que estos
investigadores nos están mostrando en
este estudio doctor Pérez Buenos días
para usted
Hola Ángela Cómo logran demostrar la
influencia de la edad biológica en el
deterioro del cerebro
acá es muy interesante es un estudio que
hacen en cerca de 250 pacientes en donde
identifican lesiones cerebrales en
pacientes que han tenido establecidas
cerebrales y hacen un estudio de la edad
biológica haciendo un estudio de
metilación de los ácidos nucleicos es
una forma de determinar el
envejecimiento celular y miran que hay
una correspondencia En cuanto la edad
biológica ha progresado hay más mayor
probabilidad de tener estos eventos
vasculares
independientemente de la edad
cronológica es decir de los años que
pasan en nuestra vida estos hallazgos
los hacen en imágenes cerebrales en
personas que han tenido lesiones y
plantean que hay un dos edades una edad
que son los años que pasan y una edad
celular que puede ser alterada alterada
modificada por los hábitos saludables y
que se manifiesta en este caso como
lesiones cerebrales hablaban en este
estudio precisamente a raíz de estas
imágenes cerebrales de un indicador no
que serán esas áreas blan el cerebro que
no se irrigan bien que no llega bien la
sangre y que por lo tanto pues hace que
haya un deterioro cognitivo eso serviría
para hacer pronósticos por ejemplo para
saber cómo Una persona puede desarrollar
este deterioro cognitivo en el futuro
Lo importante es que estos son estudios
no son verdades y los investigadores son
muy cautos en decir que esto es la parte
del inicio de una línea de investigación
es acerca de esta área
se han visto en otras patologías lo que
ellos relacionan es que algunas de estas
lesiones podrían estar correlacionados
con esta edad biológica
y lo que plantean es que se necesitan
nuevas imágenes y nuevas estudios para
poder verificar Qué importancia en Qué
sitios que se localizan estas lesiones
podrían tener relación o no con ese
envejecimiento celular o edad biológica
avanzada llamémosla de esa forma es un
estudio muy interesante pero Abre pautas
para nuevas investigaciones siendo un
Pilar pero no necesariamente una verdad
los hábitos saludables han sido toda una
discusión alrededor del estilo de vida
de la gente y además digamos que hay
muchas corrientes Pero además muchas
modas Cuáles son esos hábitos realmente
saludables que pueden influir para
retrasar el envejecimiento de nuestro
cerebro
sí Ángeles es una pregunta que los
mismos investigadores tampoco responden
dice hábitos saludables pero no hacen
referencia a cuál lo que sí tenemos que
tener claro es que afecta nuestra salud
por ejemplo el consumo de drogas El
consumo excesivo de alcohol las
comorbilidades la obesidad los malos
hábitos de alimentación comiendo grasas
saturadas elementos ultraprocesados
deterioran y aceleran digamos esos
procesos vasculares que pueden empeorar
las acciones Aquí no hay un remedio ni
una comida mágica ni un medicamento
mágico que nos quite el envejecimiento
lo que hace es que hay algunas cosas en
exceso como el alcohol las drogas la las
grasas saturadas la mala alimentación
que podrían empeorar y acelerar ese
hábito biológico más que tomar algo es
evitar algunas cosas pues eh doctor el
agradecimiento para usted el
agradecimiento también para amar por
ilustrarnos en este tema a dormir bien a
comer bien hacer ejercicio y Bueno A
buscar una vejez saludable más que nada
a
Bueno pues muchas gracias es el momento
de hacer una pausa y ya volvemos con más